it was a muted day in the capital the
threat of russian airstrikes hung over
independence day as did the memory of
those killed fighting in the defense of
the country's freedom
britain has been one of ukraine's
closest allies during the six month war
it is no exaggeration to say that boris
johnson is adored by many ukrainians and
he came here in secret today to mark the
anniversary
this is now a war
for that independence
and history teaches us that when a
country has
a language an identity
a pride
a love of its traditions
a patriotic feeling that simply grows
with every month and year
that passes
when a country of that kind is engaged
in a war
for its very existence
i tell you my friends
that war
is only going to end
one way
ukraine will win
some leaders have already saying that
we've done so much what do you want what
else do you want from me now the prime
minister johnson
always said what else the uk can do for
for ukraine to win
as ukraine will definitely be victorious
i think that's the major essence of the
relations of uk to to ukraine and this
respect and the friendly relations in
between of us
normally an annual military parade would
take place on the vast boulevard that
runs through the centre of kiev
independence from the soviet union is
something they celebrate
instead the street was full of russian
weapons destroyed during their doomed
advance of the city in those frightening
days that started in late february
they are now monuments to russian
failure and a symbol of ukrainian
resistance
vladimir putin thought that russian
forces would capture kiev within days
they failed this
is not the military parade that he
imagined
instead his forces are bogged down in a
war
that they're unwilling to leave and so
far incapable of winning
on the front line the fighting continued
mikolaiv in the south is bombed every
day
barely a street is untouched
an airstrike on mikolayev blew out the
rear bova's windows onto their sleeping
granddaughter
the windows are now boarded up which
gives them some protection but of course
it also blocks the light so their
electricity is on more than normal and
that costs them money they don't have
numbers
she shows us what little they have left
the month they couldn't even afford
bread this morning
every morning people in the city venture
outside to see who is alive and who is
not
that's been the grim reality of life
here
for six long months
alastair bunker sky news
in ukraine